[Music]
why do I hate the Big Bang Theory so
much you think I'd be the perfect
audience for the show the subject matter
of the show is admirable it's about a
group of scientists who appreciate comic
book science fiction video games you
know the finer things but it ultimately
has as much to do with geek culture as
Greenacres has to do with agriculture
characters on the show merely mentioned
cosplay or lightsabers or Dungeons &
Dragons and the studio audience busts a
gut well who's the best superhero can't
ask a question like that in here you
trying to start a rumble where was the
punchline the geeks on Big Bang Theory
aren't being laughed with they're being
laughed at am I actually supposed to be
delighted to hear a reference to Star
Trek on a network TV show so we tell
Spock all that stuff he knew wasn't true
like saying Spock didn't Kara's mom died
I missed Comic Con II I'm the new Star
Trek I'll be delighted when I see a new
Star Trek show on network television
thanks very much
my theory is Big Bang Theory has to pile
on pop cultural references because the
characters are fundamentally
uninteresting they're obtuse socially
malodorous grown men pruned too childish
emotional outbursts clinging to the pop
culture they're you obsessing over petty
distinctions that mean absolutely
nothing to any normal
[Music]
oh let's let's cut it there let's cut it
there I need to spend some time alone in
quiet reflection like Spock at the
beginning of never mind never mind not
like that
what popular geek touchstone do you
despise let me know in the comments also
I hate that the Big Bang Theory has
literally trademarked the meaningless
catchphrase bazinga
what bazinga I don't care not a word not
funny
[Music]